how are you by the way
so good love you
doing well doing well pleasure to be
with you same
yeah
i'm like
ridiculously excited for this one
hold your pants on man
we'll see what happens in the 90 minutes
yeah
oh man
cool
so we're we're rolling
and yeah let's just shoot the [ __ ] let's
do it so
so anna brown right
yeah so anna brown is the name
yeah
but the identity isn't there
oh
yeah but there's a personality for sure
there's a character just like there's a
character there
cool so start unpacking this for us
yeah yeah so there's only oneness
there's only wholeness there's only that
which we want to call god and it's
appearing as everything
everything from the shittiest thing we
can think of to the most glorious thing
we can think of it is everything
and yet
simultaneously nothing meaning our mind
or brains can't comprehend
this mystery that is appearing as this
voice in that voice
but it is one dance it just seems to be
spliced in two
you see but this is just one reflection
so the dream of seeking
the idea that i'm going to be on a
really hard path with all my tools and
work on myself really hard and decide or
dissect myself like operation the game
operation i will get closer to
enlightenment to liberation to the
godhead
and all i can say is that's a fallacy
it's a misconception this already
is the godhead appearing as a human or
you could say this is being
a human beingness appearing as a human
hence the human being you see but the
dream is no i'm just a human i'm going
to find a beingness
you won't ever find it because it's not
missing
it's already appearing as you
yeah wonderful
cool
so
how do you feel about
it
being a question mark with itself
hmm
well i would say oneness knows itself
it but it's it's an intuitive knowing
it's an intuitive recognition so it's
the elimination of doubt when there's no
longer seeking so there's no doubt here
there's there's a natural confidence but
i don't know
it's kind of like being a kid there's an
innocence but children have a natural
confidence to them because they're
naturally beingness right they're not
convoluted by dogma and religion and uh
cultures yet they're just they're just
their natural self right so if we can
omit the word enlightenment and just use
organic or authenticity or natural that
really takes like a heavy load off all
right because
those are just stories
all of those are just
stories so
so
there is the apparent
cessation of story that then
seems to um
create
greater
um awakeness to said question mark
like the story
say that one more time
so like
the cessation of story
narrative
sense of self and others
yes
seems to create greater awakeness to the
mystery that one is
that this is
i'm not sure how to answer that but i i
get what you're saying you could say the
person who feels like they have free
will and choice that is separate from
the whole
it seems to cover this it seems to
shroud this and it thinks kind of like
in spirituality i can elevate my
consciousness i can raise my vibration
and that's a misunderstanding that's
that's not what we're speaking about
here those are states states don't last
we're speaking about something that is
stateless but can appear as all states
um what we're speaking about it knows
itself it is itself what doesn't know
itself is the one chasing its own tail
and it's constantly in doubt that's why
it likes to change belief systems like
underwear writer hairdos because it
hides behind beliefs it hides behind
stories because it's afraid so to speak
of this and there's nothing wrong with
seeking there's nothing wrong with
feeling like you're autonomous outside
of the whole because that is the
absolute if we're really hearing this
we're saying that everything
even the dream of seeking
is liberation
yeah yeah yeah
paradox damn it yeah love that i love
the
all of the different
webs of beliefs and just hiding behind
those
um is the great game it seems like
um yeah yeah because it or it can be not
so great it really depends on the belief
system right atlas yeah some belief
systems aren't very uh jubilant
yeah
mm-hmm
yeah so do you feel like the
simultaneity of already being it and yet
also the appearance of
the
kind of cessation of those belief
systems do you feel like a simultaneity
there and kind of pointing people to
that
well beliefs fall you don't no long you
don't no longer need a belief they can
still arise old belief systems old
memories or anything can seem to arise
no one's super interested in them
anymore because what we're speaking
about is being life it doesn't need
beliefs and i like to say if we look at
the word belief in the english language
it says be lie
lies right in the middle now if you move
that e to the end
we have be life
so we're talking about a perception
shift
going from personal to impersonal
and and there's no goal with this this
isn't a teacher and i have no goal for
you to shift because from here it's seen
everything is the absolute and in
perfect harmony
it just won't make sense to what we call
our minds or brains because the brain is
cut into two hemispheres it can only
operate in black and white right and
wrong in comparison
yeah it resonates a lot um when we share
it as a perceptual shift and so then
there seems to be a lot of um
uh like questions that arise by it
asking itself
through others
about how to obtain said perceptual
shift
[Music]
okay so first thing to know i didn't
reach anything and i didn't attain
anything so the one who was trying to
reach trying to attain through effort
dissolved or disappeared like fog on a
sunny day because it wasn't real it was
illusory
okay and so we can't reach this how can
we reach it when it's already appearing
as breath
it's appearing as this conversation now
self-consciousness
is the dream of humanity which is the
ability to observe oneself
dissociate detach
micromanage look at oneself and then
tinker and try to manipulate and control
that is illusory it's the absolute
appearing as that there is no control
there is absolutely no control so the
idea that you
you who is outside of the hole can bring
itself closer to the hole through
practice
is imagination it's not real because
there is only wholeness appearing as a
you trying to get closer to it nice and
that's heard when it's heard you know
what i mean it
it rings when it rings
yeah
yeah this is where i feel like
this is like this is really the crux of
it i mean
um
how many years has it been now just
honing like honing in on this and um
like
the ability to share it
and
like because there is that like sense of
compassion there's that sense of loving
kindness that like radiates because
there is like so much sincerity truly
coming from
it to itself asking about what it is
and yeah and so at this like crux we
could say
is yes the pointing of you're already it
looking for itself and that's already
wholeness like there is that like direct
pointing of like you know the cessation
of separation and whatnot locality story
all those things and yet at the same
time at that same crux point is the okay
well
although i have this direct pointing in
access
i also
am so overwhelmed by my own habits of
simulating a sense of self and others
and separation and story and so then
there is also like just simply
just meditation or like relaxation of
the stories and of the sense of self
right so through breath through
focus through concentration like that
can also yield greater access to said
crux point do you also feel similarly
curious well i would well that would be
us practicing into it that would be more
like a therapy or a therapeutic process
which there's nothing wrong with it
that's very intelligent if one feels
separate if one feels like they're in a
prison cell it it makes sense to do
those things but the seeker you are the
prison cell
until that scene
it's always going to be decorating the
prison cell with very beautiful things
hence the spiritual path the religious
path the therapeutic path the self-help
path but there isn't a self to help
and that's why this is not a popular
message um you know what i mean because
it's there if there's no handouts
there's no
here's a mantra here's a meditation this
is going to help you kind of thing it's
a really hopeless message because what
we're suggesting is even the neurosis
even the habits are the absolute
appearing as habits of neurosis but what
i can share is what seemed to arise here
is when this was heard by no one when
this was seen by no one the neurotic
stuff kind of started to slowly fall off
the habits started to not appear as
intensely
for some it's just boom game over you
know what i mean like what are you even
talking about didn't even miss a beat
this year was stubborn so it seemed like
things took a bit the neurotic stuff
takes a bit to kind of fall off right
but there's still going to be natural
emotions all natural emotions arise
anger frustration sadness gladness all
of those things appear but now there's
no longer an idea of oh
i got angry i better go heal some [ __ ]
or i better go meditate away the anger
because that means i'm not there yet
but all emotions all sensations are of
the one source
so nothing is denied everything is
included obviously uh frustration feels
different than gratitude but there's no
longer someone going not you oh yeah
coming gratitude not you sadness you
know what i mean it's a
everything is welcome to be
naturally as it is
so crying may arise you know
going punch in a tree i don't know to
get to get angered out all of that may
arise but when we're on a spiritual path
we're told hey if you're enlightened if
you're there
you won't ever get angry you're going to
love all your neighbors you know what i
mean you'll never cuss you know you'll
become a vegetarian whatever the fantasy
is and then when we hear it's already
appearing as everything including the
emotions you're shoving into a box and
labeling do not open
you see because when we have these types
of philosophies
what we call negativity can seem to be
inflamed and visit us more often than
not because we're seeing it as an enemy
like satan or an ego there isn't one
there's only the absolute appearing is
all and that's why many would say sages
or
masters if you would say have no
enemy because there isn't one there is
no other and that includes emotions and
thoughts it's all the absolute dancing
and prancing
nice yeah there's something
so important about this
um as is sort of called nowadays
uncompromising
let's say pointing
um yeah
it's
cr it's really critical i feel
um
and yet there's also something about it
that feels um a little bit like
um
like it doesn't always meet
uh
the
other self let's say where
they're at
sometimes no way yeah no way well it's
because
when we're coming to someone usually
it's for help
this is speaking directly to the one
that's awake confident alive and doesn't
need help in the endeavors of
enlightenment you may need help making
cookies i use that example a lot i like
sweets you may need help cleaning your
house
and and maybe someone will come and help
you do that but when it's like i need
help reaching what you're talking about
anna i can only hold up a mirror and tap
your nose
you see
yeah
and
so
it's great so that
so let's say that when you do that
that then
there's the
the spectrum of responses let's say
where you totally right so you have like
the direct right oh my gosh of course
[ __ ] yeah i got it you know type thing
and then there's the um i don't get it
i'm still suffering and
yeah so then do you keep
tapping them on them do you keep doing
that same process mirror nose tap or
what absolutely i don't do it though i
don't do it so when there's no longer a
person there's no longer a sense of
separation it doesn't connect and relate
in the levelless sense of separation you
see like oh let's do this or let's do
that because this is a bird's eye view
seeing
there is no chooser
there is no doer
what will be will be so to speak all of
this is chaos appearing orderly
there isn't a separate chooser
but
to what i'm speaking of everyone knows
if you will you know this
i know this that's why there's a
resonance so there can be a deep like oh
my god
yes i know exactly what you're speaking
about
and then the beliefs may start to arise
sure so what
they have no meaning
at all so you're right yes this can only
abide in the reflection but that doesn't
mean there's not compassion or empathy
right
so yeah would you say that what
comes through after the
first tap on the nose with the mirror
and then the not getting it
is still the same tap on the nose with
the mirror or is there an adjustment
that organically occurs
oh it's always organic because each
character is different and only life
knows what to say to life a mind has no
idea what to say it's always like well
let's
i don't know [ __ ] you know but life
knows what to say to itself because
it just does it's it's everything and
nothing so of course it knows what to
say
but it's spontaneous and it's organic
and it's off the cuff it's not
pre-cogged if you will
that's what frightens the sense of
separation it wants everything planned
and pre-cog so the eyes are dotted and
then teased across
but this is natural spontaneity and it's
just yeah it's just like dancing or
making love you know it's just
here we go this way and
you know yeah i can't say what's coming
next
yeah
so then you feel
you feel
would you say hollow or empty
oh no it's a simultaneity
so the fullness is empty and the
emptiness is full or formlessness is
form
paradox it can't be got but i like to
use the example of quantum physics the
atom which is 99.99999
space and this is apparently made of
atoms
so i mean science is even starting to
get close to that pointing
you see that it that spaciousness or uh
the chaos of potentiality appears as a
particle
appears as a particle we have to say
this is an appearance like a dream at
night so there's nothing behind this
nothing in front of it it's not going
anywhere it didn't come from anywhere
because cause and effect isn't actually
real it only seems to be
and i have to say this is as mysterious
to this is there there's just no longer
doubt
from stories and dogma so there's just
an innocence and this innocence speaks
to the innocence that is all
yeah
[Music]
yeah
so of course there's uh the simultaneity
of empty fullness and
um
and of course there's the
the mystery with itself or whatever fill
in the blank with itself dancing right
so
so that's that's become
just so um
yeah
without
a
shadow of a doubt um
and
the freedom let's say uh from that is
um which it of course always already is
that
um but then but then the game that it
plays where it apparently masks or veils
itself from that
um
[Music]
that at that like let's i i'm it's nice
continuing to reference it as some sort
of like a crux point or like a source
point or whatever you will however you
if you will that whatever source point
crux point of
like freedom
um
in a sense seemingly veiling itself
to
some sort of illusion of separation
location sense of self whatnot
limits limits basically limits right
yeah yeah
but limits still appear
and a sense of location still arises so
i'm not over here feeling like a blob of
lsd or something no there's definitely a
sense of body and location for some they
can have the experience or like a
glimpse of just awareness is everything
if you will if we want to use that word
but a sense of location comes back those
types of things don't last right there's
a sense of locale i'm not walking
through walls you know like a ghost or
something you see so we don't get rid of
being human it's just human is finally
accepted by no one
you see the ideas of i'm just a human or
i was born and i will die they all go
this is already paradise pretending but
going to your crux
um there's not you could say everything
is the point a pointless point but we
can look at it just as an x it's just
one big x this is the x marks the spot
always
for the purses and they got the treasure
map right and they're like oh my god
where's the x
where's the [ __ ] x man and it's on
your forehead
it's on your [ __ ] forehead
and everywhere
you know
it's not funny though when you you know
you're looking forward kind of like when
you have your glasses on your head and
you're like holy crap
yeah
yeah
yeah but nothing changes nothing changes
but you could say everything is
transformed so um you know this the zen
cohen of before in light the chop would
carry water after enlightenment chop
would carry water
rolls arise
the show goes on for no one
hmm
so
so if we play and i say that i don't get
no one
how
how do you
how does it share with itself
at that crux
to like
i'm not in a crux and
yeah
it's not i'm not in the crux there's no
crux to share
this another way to say this how does
freedom because it feels like the entire
game is played
where
freedom liberates itself from its own
illusions
it seems like that and we hear that a
lot too but what if there isn't deep in
the game
you see
we can use we can go into that as soon
as we start to go into like explaining
this we're weaving a web
of which
we can get stuck in like a fly you know
um what if there's not even a game
you see what i'm saying by that because
if there's a game there's a winner and a
loser we're in the we're in the dream of
duality there really isn't separation
separation appears
so if you mean like the show goes on
yeah there's a show that goes on
watching netflix goes on making dinner
goes on folding laundry goes on
apparently it's an appearance
um
but there's no one up in the sense of
like i'm going to get to enlightenment
that's because it's it's it's just a
story
there is no such thing you could say
there is only enlightenment
nice so
let's call that like simultaneity of
game and no game
because
as soon as
there is
this conversation appearing of freedom
liberating itself from illusion that's
the creation of illusion or that's the
creation of game let's say and there is
no game being played because
everything's already free and liberated
as we've as we've referenced
cool
and yet there is also the appearance of
the game
when there's a seeker
when there's a you there who feels like
they're in control right but it's not
real
nothing is real
and you can hear that both possible ways
nothing is
appearing to be real
it doesn't make any logical sense
only intuitive yeah
because you see in the dream which there
isn't one that's why no one wakes up
because there's nobody asleep
that's why it's so hard to wake up
you're not asleep
you see but but in the dream of seeking
it's something needs to change first
but nothing will change
that idea seems to dissolve
and with that it seems either quickly or
slowly the the neurosis of the character
but i gotta say even old neurosis can
seem to appear they just don't have the
charge as they used to
you see because most of the time those
types of energies like ocd and anxiety
come from the idea of time being real my
past being real in my future being very
real and important
with that too is it yeah
crap
because this is perfection appearing
it's just it won't ever make sense to
the brain
right it perfection usually to is is
very personal this is what perfection
looks like for me right
right but we're speaking about a
perfection that's beyond mind perfection
beyond the ideas of the world
but appears as the world
that's why you know jesus
in the world yet not of it
in other words formlessness is formed
so it's kind of incognito you know
because you could be eating a pretzel or
slurping down a beer and no one's home
but to an outsider it's like oh my god
hello vibrational
or whatever right how human how early
meanwhile there's no one home
yeah because it's it's beyond all these
ideas of what is right what is wrong
what is good what is bad what is higher
and lower all hierarchies
land in the [ __ ]
you see
but there's still the play of talking
and words and all of these types of
things that go on you know we're not
just walking around like a mute
or a statue you know how boring
it's uh two
fun threads i feel to pull there
yeah let's pull on the most recent one
so
so the
absolute dissolution of hierarchy and
yet also the appearance of when
something tragic happens
that there is the
going to
the
highest let's say doctor
so highest doc what do you mean by the
highest doctor like are you talking
about a medical doctor yes
yes oh okay yeah i mean yeah they're
still like the looking for the best
doctors or schools or i don't know
hair salon to go to yeah totally that's
already what's happening though yeah yes
and so this is another fun place to like
share is the intention
yeah so where there's
both like no hierarchy and appearing
hierarchy like that
is really important and then the other
one that's very similar with that
entanglement is
the
the nothing is real
and yet also without a doubt
it's also appearing
yeah
and so
this this is again that like entangled
of
yeah yeah like
it's like a braid
yeah like a dna like a double helix yeah
you can't you can't separate them
yeah
nice
yeah
that's your stairway to heaven by the
way yeah stairway to heaven it's just
like that the brave the double it double
helix it's entwined it can't be
separated
you can try to
that's the headache right this the
trying to is oh i've got a mind
i've got an ego i've got a soul i've got
a past i've got a future
actually we don't have anything
damn i love uh
i love the
um
the entangled
share where um
like
the
reference to a braid or the double helix
and just how that is the stairway to
heaven i i love that that just feels yes
that feels really good yeah it's you
it's you
it's it looks like a [ __ ] ladder
anyways right i mean come on
not funny
so wonderful
and that's why wonderfully nothing right
yeah and absolutely everything
so we're not denying form but yeah
wonderfully nothing absolutely
everything yeah
cool
and that doesn't mean again that it's
you you love
everyone in the sense of like oh kumbaya
let's all get together there's
definitely preferences and resonances
and
all of that you know
but again that's already what's
appearing birds of a feather flock
together or don't you know but now let's
say what seems to not arise is the guilt
because i could say when this character
seemed to be in the spiritual community
it was like gotta get along with
everybody if i don't you know maybe
there's something to heal they're clear
or there might be some guilt or shame
for the behaviors of the character
finally the character is accepted for
what it is which could be very taboo-ish
you could be seen as an [ __ ] i can't
say but finally there's no guilt shame
or insecurity for the character traits
it's it's naturally celebrated but that
doesn't mean everyone's going to like
you it doesn't mean you're gonna like
everybody and i know these words sound
very dualistic um but i mean look at
nature
um some plants can't grow next to each
other because they'll literally choke
each other out you know and some animals
they you know it's all there's natural
boundaries and harmonies and lions eat
gazelles
you know but they're not like oh my god
my karma
you know
none of that arises because they don't
have self-consciousness it's an
immediacy it's a seamlessness it's a
primordial intelligence
you see
um yeah self-consciousness is that
ability to kind of hover and and pull
back and fractal into two which no one's
choosing to do that no one's choosing to
do that it's kind of like a reflex like
an allergic reaction it's just
boundless energy appearing as that yeah
interesting share that last sentence a
little bit more
oh dear boundless energy expressing is
that otherwise it's all gone
and one more and one more before that i
i feel like it was basically sharing
that um freedom can appear to choose to
have a sense of self in a body oh yes
and it does not give a [ __ ] and i gotta
be oneness does not care about seeing
this so to speak
it's not important
this message is not like going door to
door and oh my god come to the carnival
you gotta hear this message it's gonna
change your life there's there's no life
to change
there can be a resonance and that
resonance is what is already awake what
is already alive what is already
confident and knows this that's why i
say hey y'all this is a reflection you
know this it'd be arrogant for me to say
that i know more than you i don't
we're just two friends chatting about
what we intuitively know
you know and it just comes out of this
character this instrument in in a
certain way but another instrument or
character it may sound a little
different but but it is truly all one
breath
many instruments
some are kind of noisy though i don't
listen at all
i like how you just simply brought in a
very organic example of
certain plants not being able to grow
next to each other or just the way that
there is a prey and predator type of
dynamic that happens in the natural
biological expression of what we are
what it is and so because of that it's
very similar to why there is an apparent
polarity between political parties or
whatnot
yes
yes as long as there is form atlas there
will have to be apparent polarities
day and night black and white hot and
cold
predator and prey
sinner and saint
but the good news is is the sinner is
the saint and the predator is the prey
[Music]
you see but when we're on a spiritual
path of religious it's
oh no no none of that evil stuff none of
that sinner stuff none of that heathen
stuff no darkness well you are the
darkness as well as the light you're
everything and as long as there is that
not that
not that
we're living in that boxing ring
i won this match oh you're going to get
your ass laid out the next match it's
always going to be that kind of you know
what i mean that that game of tug-of-war
tug of war and tug of war can still
appear and a boxing match
you know when it's seen that by knowing
that this is it it's just now that
competitive mind of intense arrogance
and this is what's going to fulfill me
collapses now maybe there's just boxing
for the joy of it
huggle war because i don't know that's
fun falling on your face in the mud i
don't know
you know it's just a character trait
oh yay
we don't all have to wear white
or like give up our crossfits or our you
know our
whatever it is yeah
our pizza or beer yeah
thank goodness
i like how you said that as long as
there is
form
the assumption let's say or belief of
form there will also be
the let's say ignorance of uh knowing
that it is both appearing polarities
and then that creates
um feelings of suffering um
well i wouldn't say that nothing creates
anything so
it's not that the polarities are wrong
as long as there's an appearance of form
there's going to be the balancing
you know just
that's just this how it appears if
there's form it'll be the opposite and
then see
seeing through form is then what yields
let's say um or appears to yield through
an appearance of a process
insight into formlessness which then
makes it
seen through that the form is
i or it appearing as poles
you could you could say that i mean in
the story of anna it was
this year it went impersonal you could
say there was a collapse in realizing
i was nothing i had nothing i own
nothing none of this was real
um and that led to like a desert period
which i felt kind of hopeless um all
beliefs were kind of tempting me like
jesus in the desert right
tempting and so all of these types of
things were falling away felt completely
hopeless because nothing was real
that's the wisdom
but the love part that joy part that
bliss part is the recognition that you
are everything you're the body
yeah you're the apparent the appearance
of mind of of personality everything
that's arising that's the love part
until that is seen by no one it's kind
of like oh
you don't want anything to do with form
you don't you don't you want to get away
from it which is kind of a masculine
energy of let's detach
like self-inquiry let's hover let's pull
away from body let's pull away from
world and we're talking
a complete collapse in the body complete
collapse into everything
no one's trying to tinker with it
anymore
in that sense of i need to alter
something to reach something called god
or enlightenment but there can be let's
say altering the diet starting a new rec
or exercise regimen
because there's a joy there there's a
joy to move there's a joy to dance
there's a joy to express and create not
because i'm going to get closer to god
through it
because that's already what is it's just
paradise playing
for no reason for no point for no
purpose just like kids
on the jungle gym
welcome to the jungle baby
yeah i like how you talk about it um
when you reference the
like
desert period of i am nothing and then
the um
collapse
um of that with the i am everything and
then the
the cessation of needing to do something
to be what one already is
um i feel like that's really powerful
um
[Music]
and then there's also the like
there's also like the story of what
you
a a the appearance of your story which
is
that for some some amount of again years
that there was
a sense of you
being your identity and then
shifting into what we just described
right but i have to be clear it didn't
lead to this because you could say
since a very young age there was
glimpses so there'd be dropping of
identity when i was really little and
they would come back drop come back so
when and when it was dropped it was very
obvious that this was heaven in disguise
but then my beliefs
anna the you know the seeking would come
back in and go oh my god what was that
you know trying to find it through
spirituality or you know what i mean
trying to investigate and get back to it
not recognizing that that glimpse was
this just appearing as a person trying
to find itself
um so yeah the opening and the closing
seemed to arise here that doesn't have
to rise for every character there is no
poster child for this
so that's why we can't look to any
character and go oh well she you know
she had a glimpse as a child i didn't
have that so it's never going to happen
or whatever nothing is happening and
it's not going to happen to you
this already is it
how you're sitting how you're breathing
how you're blinking
is the manifestation of totality
perfection
yeah
and thoughts still arise and emotions
still arise
yeah it's not about a silent mind
that can arise too but you know already
thoughts are the absolute thinking
emotions are the absolute
emotioning
feeling you know yeah
just like you don't choose the weather
hmm
hmm
that's all we really can do
so
i feel this is another good um way to
play on this is that
um you have you have kids is it just one
two
two six year old and a seven month old
almost day basically we'll say eight
month old
did you say a six year old and uh
an eight month old oh yeah
cool cool
um
and so
you've sort of had the opportunity to
see
um
that
like
life
having like the ability to
um
like lose itself in its sense of
identity or like that flickering in a
sense
yeah i saw that with my first daughter
luna and when she was around the age of
two uh
i mean because it's just pure beingness
it's just pure beingness you know i'm
going into a story now here but around
the age of like two two and a half she
would like there would be moments where
yeah like a flicker she would hold her
head and she would go my mind
my mind my mind's coming and i would
just sit there and just be like oh like
whoa you know like this is
unusual and interesting and yeah then it
would drop
so yeah i could see that condition
coming in and when i was raising luna
you know there was still seeker energy
here right so you know there's still
some of that kind of all you know
teaching going on with that because
there was still a contraction here
there's still a seeking here
um so yeah but there was nothing wrong
with that of course just like there's
nothing wrong with the hand-me-downs
from my folks or communities and all of
that it's just what seems to be
happening or arising but yeah i totally
witnessed that within um with luna
but no one here wants to change that
you see yeah
she has questions this naturally
responds and answers you know and there
is times where she reports to me mom i
feel like nothing
i don't feel like anything
and i don't know if i belong in this
world you know she'll say things like
this sometimes you know and it's like
yeah it's okay honey it's okay
you know she's only six so we can't go
into this kind of lingo here you know
you gotta use certain words but there's
a natural response that comes out you
know what i mean like to a question she
has or something she shares it's just
very natural and spontaneous like i said
life knows what to say to itself
and when to say it
cool so yeah it sounds like there hasn't
been in
a solidity that has built up in luna
yeah and then that what um
that plays um into why there's um
like the communication of something like
i don't feel like any like i feel like
i'm nothing or i feel like i'm not
anything and
it's like a freedom of not
being a thing
right but for her sometimes it's like
because there is what we would call a
sense there is a sense of self there
right there's a sense of separation
she'll come in and she'll be like this
is kind of weird or i don't like the way
it feels or you know stuff like that you
know we'll talk about it but yeah i mean
just like within the apparent human here
or the character right there can be
those what we're calling glimpses or
oscillations
right and when the person comes back or
something and maybe like what was that
that was really weird
you know or be really afraid or i can't
say depends on the character but
i mean i can report that things are very
odd i can't explain it yeah i mean my
goodness
of course it's odd
it's hotter than yeah
so
mm-hmm
and um
is was uh did i remember this right your
eight-month-old is is maya is that right
right leela
such
um
and so
and yeah leela and luna cool so there's
some consideration there that's
fun yeah that's cool
so
um
interesting
so leela hasn't yet hit
um
they're both girls right
right yes
and um she hasn't yet hit
um
a uh
the formation of any sense of identity
right
no like when mama leaves the room i
don't exist i'm not there anymore and
that's very scary for a baby because to
them they don't have space-time
perception so when a ball rolls under
something i leave the room or i take a
toy away it's gone forever and that's
why babies will cry where'd mommy go
because like to them they're not there
they're not better and then i come back
right like the game peekaboo too if you
ever play peekaboo the little one you're
totally gone that's why when you come
back from the hands it's like whoa and
they start laughing hysterically because
you like just came out of the ethers
literally um so yeah it's just being
this and it's just just like with any
baby or just anyone there's all human
functioning it's all natural functioning
there's crying there's getting
frustrated there's giggling there's
farting there's puking
eating all of that arises and that's
that's that's natural
yeah
and that that does remain that does stay
thank god because i love food
so
you know
chop would carry water
it's just seen everything is an
appearance and it's not on a train track
and
time is most definitely a construct not
real so
but it is mysterious how aging seems to
appear evolution seems to appear
progression seems to appear
i mean i have to underline scenes too
just like in the dream at night
[Music]
so
uh no no amount of
calling this
um a dream is
also going to um
make the dream in a sense stop
as though it it goes on even though you
know it's a dream
it knows itself as a dream
you could say it's like i mean
like i said forgive the words because no
word i say is going to encapsulate what
we're speaking about we're just trying
to paint a picture that can't be painted
so it's like you know we're doing the
best we can right um but
you say it's like a lucid dream
the one knows this is a dream the one
knows this isn't real
but that doesn't mean there's not pain
that doesn't mean there's not sensations
that doesn't mean there's not challenges
oh there totally is
but for no one suffering can appear as
well but there's not personal suffering
and that's a big let's we're using the
word wake-up call but for one let's say
that's been on a spiritual a religious
path because it's like we got to get rid
of the the pain stuff we got to get rid
of that lower stuff you know
um but it's like no that's that's it too
that's it too
but i can just share what seems to stop
arising is that that intense kind of
neurotic energy
of where am i going where have i been
let's alter shift and change these
things but you don't have dementia
you know what i mean like
yeah
you don't have dementia that's what's
funny is it comes to recognize there
never needed to be an eye to do anything
talking still goes on walking goes on
holding the dishes goes on no one was
ever doing it so ownership dissolves
yeah
it's amazing
absolutely amazing
i really can't explain
but atlas
this character here in atlas
it's just like no different than like a
tree or a sunflower or
a park bench
the park bench is naturally being itself
the tree is naturally being itself the
birds are naturally beating itself
you know and they kind of hum in energy
yeah this is no different than the chair
or the leaf or the bird
[Music]
this just seems to have the ability to
talk and sometimes too much but
yeah
yeah i like uh lucid dream i feel that's
great
it covers like you could say both
it's a very entangled state
and it's a it's a nice uh
it's a nice way to describe the this
the indescribable um
mm-hmm
do you
do you feel a
do you feel like what the indescribable
is as much again like you've said as we
can
play on this
um which seems to be one of the most fun
things that it can do is
uh try and talk about itself because
it's um
unable to but it's uh it's fun too um
yeah
um
do you do you feel like a paint brush
is a
is a fun way
to describe it
yeah you could say you're simultaneously
the paintbrush and the painter
it's hard and it's like any time we use
these types of things though it's like
if there's a person listening they're
gonna be like okay well i'm just the
brush i don't do anything
i don't i'm just being you know what i
mean like kind of like a puppet or
something's coming and you know what i
mean that we kind of have that dualistic
so
yeah
it's it's hard to explain you could say
this is like improv it's all off the
cuff it's all just spontaneously
erupting like an orgasm or like a big
bang it's just
[Music]
it has no intention
there's no volition
it has no destination it's trying to get
to
in the sense of purpose like i'm here on
a mission here on a purpose all of those
things seem to arise what we're talking
about is the end of the need for
intention meaning and purpose and
mission
yeah
yeah
he's obviously coming to the podcast
today looks like it getting an intention
to speak
right
but it just naturally and spontaneously
arises
versus like i'm holding an intention and
this must happen this must occur you
know
yeah
so
then we would say something like the
um
the the painter that it is
um painted this podcast
and
it is also
intention-less from a personal
perspective
well it didn't paint the podcast it's
being painted as it arises yes just like
dancing or making love like you don't
know what's going to happen next nobody
knows what's going to happen next
but that's the thrill you could say
and so
so
there is no creator if that's what
you're wondering there's no godhead
outside of this there's nothing outside
of this at all
it's the whole ocean and drop yeah yes
and yet
that is painting
this well it seems to be this isn't
actually happening and it's not going
anywhere
yeah both so as it paints it dissolves
as it paints it's erased
for the person it's concrete it's real
and my painting is important and going
somewhere
it dissolves as soon as the brush hits
the paper
it's like riding on water
yes
so
what
is
painted
can be again dissolves like in water but
can be what is dreamt
it can be
um
the choice of or the appearance of
taking something and just
just like breaking it like the device
that you're watching this on right now
sure
or it can be
the
feeling of
the
the desire for this
for it to know itself and to sort of uh
if you will share that
love
with itself it's like here
in this dream on this earth
and so there there is the sort of
contrast of
those
possibilities
and so it can express itself as those
possibilities and so there is a
there's a freedom
there's just a freedom and so
yeah so
like
freedom expressing itself as destruction
or freedom expressing itself as
awakeness and like
so
at that point of at that point of desire
is also at the crux
i would rather say there isn't a crux at
all
there's there's crooks left there is no
crux yeah it's crooks like yeah yeah
there's
yeah
yeah
like i get where you're coming from
though yeah
but this this can't be applied to
anyone's life we don't have lives
there isn't a you that's in control of
anything there's no one that's in
control of anything at all but yeah
freedom appears as i'm in control i'm
going to create this destiny for myself
and when i get to that destiny i will be
fulfilled and then you come to find out
oh well that was great but what's next
now what can i have
being a person is having a bowl with the
hole at the bottom so even if it's
filled with gold it will come out at the
bottom and then you need more we're
talking about the end of need we're
talking about the interview
but that doesn't mean life doesn't go on
look outside
you see it's all just happening by
itself so yes if that character is
driven to like wanna i don't know join a
marathon or something that may arise and
there'll be training for that but what
drops is the ownership what drops is oh
my god well i'm going to show everybody
and this is you know what i mean that
kind of arrogant me versus them kind of
thing collapses and that's why this is a
shitty message
because most beings are motivated by
fear
and lack of separation
and when it's come to see there is no
you there is no future there is no past
a lot of motivation because it's rooted
in let me prove myself let me validate
myself can totally dwindle
but what also can happen is is the exact
opposite the roles the jobs the
character had can actually become more
vibrant exuberant because there's not
insecurity there's not i need to get
somewhere else yes you know what i mean
yeah yeah yeah well i wouldn't say it's
so important it's just it's just is what
it is you know what i mean it's just
but if you're uh
a character's an [ __ ] that doesn't
mean an [ __ ] goes away you still may
appear to be an [ __ ] there's just not
guilt about being an [ __ ] anymore
so we don't all turn into mother teresa
that's that's what the seeker thinks you
know if i hear this we're all going to
be good boys and girls
and that's not what we're saying at all
and we're also saying this doesn't mean
your life will become better
there won't be a change because you're
already not there doing anything but
what can seem to stop arising is the
neurotic energy of guilt and shame and
insecurity of validation and proof
you don't need to prove anything you are
miraculously
yourself already you are the absolute
but that can like you're sharing seem to
be shared you can't share this message
because we're speaking to that which is
already whole
you can share recipe ideas share your
your knowledge of like i don't know
poodles or giraffes those types of
things but
you get what i'm trying to say here you
can't break this off
because it's already homeless you are
everything and nothing everywhere so it
can't be shared that's why i say this is
a reflection i'm just holding up a huge
mirror speaking to the one that's
already awake and knows this it's not
going to know itself through
investigation atlas i got to be clear
it already does know itself
no time will bring you closer to knowing
yourself because time is not real i'm
speaking to timelessness which is
already appearing as time
and so it just it's heard when it's hard
like a lightning bolt
and i gotta say in the story of anna
this this message was the closest thing
to home and it resonated so deeply even
though they were still seeking energy it
was just hearing this was just was
glorious yeah yeah
nice yeah there is that resonance
lightning bolt or intuition yeah yeah
whatever you want to call it yeah
um
um
where do you go
what do we do
yeah it uh it appears to
um to continue
and um
well i mean we just yeah i mean
questions seem to dissolve that's what i
mean by that question
yeah
yet it also
appears to continue
um its
its youtube channel or its uh
zoom meetings or
whatever
sharing with itself
and
um
no one's doing it this message isn't to
help anybody though just to be clear
yeah
it's a celebration
of what we all know
yeah and it's right on your heart too
which is super cute
party
yeah
interesting so
you
you know
it you know sharing
that it is a birthday party it's like an
ongoing celebration more than
like helping itself wake up it's just
more like a celebration of what it
already is
yeah celebrating that which you already
are you know
yeah
we're not we're not told this we're told
you're jojo
you're suzanne and this is what suzanne
and this is what jojo does and this is
what you're going to do you know and
there's there's nothing wrong with that
that's the absolute playing with itself
but yeah within that system so to speak
no one goes hey you know you're it
this is home
i can't i can't like i can't get over
this like entanglement or the
simultaneity of it it just seems to be
just driving everything now it just like
it's like
and it just because it's just ah like it
is the celebration it already is and yet
it there's also
it appeared to forget itself as a person
that was separate and then it appeared
to remember itself as not that
and
and there's just
there's just uh
the the way it dances is
is that and i and it's indescribable but
it's it's that superposition if you will
um
nothing and everything all this
different it's just
so
yeah and
and then there's just
whatever there's like the release or the
letting go total of the of that uh and
like there's a huge release also around
just like wanting to or like
just um
like for it to describe itself or for it
that type of thing also
um
which i is so nice also because then it
can be more like play and dance like
kids um rather than a um
like uh
i don't know i don't know i don't know
yeah i don't know either man nobody does
know the dream is i know
so yeah
yeah
i i'm right with you i don't know either
man it's funny how words appear
this doesn't know yeah this didn't get
anything but it is amazing how words
appear
it is
yeah words pointing to the wordless
yeah well the words are actually
wordless
appearing as words
yeah
or not or not pointing to itself right
it's over there yeah yeah nice or there
yeah and that's the entanglement that's
the superposition that i'm talking about
that's [ __ ] insane in it it's so oh
well that will seem to arise when there
like a self-fulfilling prophecy i get
you it seems like a self-fulfilling
prophecy so if there's an idea if it's
over there it's like there's a guru here
that goes come to me there's a teacher
going come with me which is basically
like a carrot being dangled in front of
your face or we don't like carrots maybe
it's twinkie
or doughnut and that's the person it's
always following the trail of almost
getting the treats because teachers are
waving things in front of it going
you're almost there if you do this if
you do this you'll get it so let's let's
see so so it so this is the entanglement
it
always points to itself no matter what
and yet
and yet also and yet also it appears to
not point to itself sometimes which is
the illusion of separation or whatnot
well i would say all teachers teachers
is all illusion they're for the dream
teaching enlightenment teaching
liberation it can't this can't be taught
so i wouldn't say we're talking about
the same thing this here is
uncompromising and we're saying that no
amount of effort can bring you to this
so i would say teachers of non-duality
have a different stance and position
this doesn't have any stance or position
because i'm not here to help you reach
something because there is no you to
reach anything there's only everything
appearing as a you train to reach it
[ __ ]
yeah you you were um talking about
teaching and i'm referencing um
and that's great that there's that um
just that clarity that that just came
through because this is
um
that that expression is a was about uh
teaching and there is of course
resonance here for that for that
expression totally and where
this was coming from was more like um it
can't not point to itself because
everything is it but then within that or
as that also is superpositioned where it
can point to
again like you said a carrot being
outside of itself type thing
and so then that's dream or that's
illusion but yet also it's pointing to
itself as illusion
it's a mind [ __ ]
that it is really confusing i would i
don't i don't understand that at all to
me that's super heady and very confusing
it's very simple yeah
yeah that's that that's confusing it
felt like i felt like a maze it's it's
very simple it's
if there's a teacher
saying follow me do these things that's
what i brought in teaching because
you're saying everything is pointing to
this and i would have to disagree
not everything is pointing to this
because if someone's telling you to do
something to get closer to this that's
not pointing to this
but it's still it appearing as that
which is interesting well it's not real
though
it's that's what's seen here is past
never happened so when i share the story
of anna it's real and unreal
simultaneously like i'm recalling a
dream to you so i that's where i have to
say
nothing is real
so in that dream experience of a seeker
trying to get closer it's a dream it's
not real so i can't say that that's
comparable
because the real we're speaking about is
common
to all and it's here now
it's simply as breath
it as what's looking without the
ownership of personal
you see so that's that's where words can
get interchanged i'm not saying you're
right or wrong but i'm right or wrong
like that that was really cool that's
most simple and i feel like it's most
it's most simple for especially kids or
for those that are actually seeking is
that it is what is looking without
identity or it is what is breathing
without identity
the no one that is that yeah
yeah and it's it it's not yeah it's
quick to explain weakest who just goes
that way uh again that way go that way
or
i know i get you yeah but that that
style of the pointing is so good because
it just it sort of gets cuts through
anything that the mind can put up as a
deflection
uh of it
because it totally because it goes to
what you could say is a source of that
um and then it forces it's like a
forcing function to be like no no no
it's from there it's actually
identity-less
and that that's like that's a like
resonance or lightning or intuition yeah
yeah yeah
there we go yeah yeah yeah
all right yeah you're you're a hoot
you're a [ __ ] hoot for sure thanks
man you're who it's atlas
thanks i hope the who who doesn't mean
like geez cuckoo
like you are the celebration you know
what it is
i get i get you i get you you know this
is like oh she's a hoot like she's a
whacker she's yeah which is okay
for sure freedom appearing as a
character or like a person like really
like freedom appearing
for sure well that too that too yeah for
sure for sure but if there's like a lot
that's like not blocked there and it's
oh i get what you're saying you know
what i'm saying
[Music]
yeah it's fun because of that and also
um
it
[Music]
it's cool because it pulls from many
different places also like i you know
the synthesis and distillation thing
because you're not you're not on one
specific way of you know because when we
were talking about your kids you were
talking about what scientists talk about
with evolutionary psychology and the
development of the brain and whatnot and
so you're referencing things that
um that other you won't point to or
things like that and so it's good i feel
like that's a core part to that really
the unblockage of freedom being able to
because it can it can really just
go from the place that's in that's
organically coming without being boxed
into specific totally chameleon-like
chameleon-like
absolutely
yeah
yeah
yeah chameleons perfect shape-shifting's
perfect this is
yeah so
so i'm feeling i'm feeling a couple
things um we'll rap um yes okay cool i'm
feeling like um
i'm feeling like of course thanking you
and thanking our audience thanking
nobody
yeah thank you everyone yeah
it's a self-love party we're thinking
ourselves wonderful absolutely even the
haters
oh and why hate yourself but uh yeah
it does happen you know it's the drama
oh leela oh
the play
so
we would love for you to check out um
the links in the bio below so we have
anna's youtube channels down there she's
got tons of great content on the channel
also shorts
great shorts also love that content so
good
um
the website's there the patreon is there
so you can support that way if this
resonates lightning bolts you can
support that way
um
like the video helps the algorithm um
also subscribe to the channel if you
haven't yet comment below with your
thoughts on the episode would be fun to
to just get down there and play together
in the community both of us can can jam
down there with you
um share the video also that's also
powerful um if you feel like it
resonates share it with others you feel
like it could resonate with
and
i feel um i feel like jamming together
you know whenever it arises we'll just
um we'll just message each other and and
we'll potentially do another jam session
just see what freedom how it wants to
appear and play with itself because
this was lit it was fun yeah it was fun
man it was a fun dance very very
beautiful so just shoot me an email and
i don't know are you you're going to
shimmy off this recording can i ask you
a few questions is that okay oh for sure
yeah do you want to i know you're just
running should i end the recording and
then ask the questions or do you want to
you know oh no i was just going to say
because i wasn't sure if you were
addressing your audience there which i
think you were but i was going to say if
you if you want to send me a copy of
this i can upload it
yeah i can upload this to youtube too if
you send me a copy of this is whatever
for sure i will tell you i will okay
yeah because that's also been a fun
thing is like most recently the guests
that have come on the show also have
their own channels and whatnot and so
then we're like we're co-uploading it
and then there yeah our audience will
come and check out what we're up to our
audience will check out you're up to
type things so i will i'll send you
right
and you guys saw
on the version that anna uploads you can
check out the links in the bio below to
things like um no limit society um
or like what is i or high level
perception or our youtube channel just
some of the things that we've authored
and created so you can check out all
that stuff um
sweet so i will send that to you and
then yeah we'll see whenever the dance
of course continues and whatnot
let's wrap this by the way let's wrap
this pause the recording and then um you
and i let's just stay in the zoom room
for a minute okay
okay yeah that's yeah that's cool okay
cool
bye everyone
peace much love
you